Hi everyone, hi.
>> This is my twin brother Palter,
he loves phones and shopping.
>> Sup.
>> Hi.
All right, so
well the question today is what do
you want out of a shopping list app?
>> That's a great question.
What do you think, Palter?
>> Well, I think what you really-
>> Okay, I know instarritos.
>> Whoa, interrupt much?
>> Sorry, Paul.
>> It's Paulter.
It's a family name.
>> Okay.
to clarify multi touch
Instarrito interface.
>> I have a better idea.
>> What about an app that let's you take
regular drivers like you and me, and
pick each other up and
go to the grocery store.
>> Isn't that Uber?
>> Ooh, or
64 bit synchronized Instarrito support.
>> What is that even?
Look, I think we really need to
be focusing on the gut reaction.
Right?
So maybe even have swipe support.
Swipe right for cream puffs,
swipe left for broccoli.
>> I don't know.
That's ridiculous.
Who wants to be swiping for
their food all day.
Now cloud based API.
>> This is a shopping list app, right?
>> Mm-hm.
Yeah.
>> I'm not even sure how
you add stuff to the list.
How do you add items to the list?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so I've got a great
idea about what to do next.
>> Yeah?
>> Wasn't trained by developing
that Instaritto API, but
I think we should focus on building
out the core app functionality.
Here, let me show you.
Here's our [INAUDIBLE] again and
in version to the app, we're going
to work on the shopping list screen and
the shopping list details screen.
Right now the shopping list
screen only has one list, but
instead what I want is for
us to have a collection of lists.
Now, you should be able to click
on each of these lists, and
it will take you to a shopping
list detail screen,
which is where will actually
show what items are in the list.
And then we'll be allowing users
to collaboratively add and
remove items from any of these lists.
>> To do that, you and
the developer are going to need to
a lot more than just set value.
You'll need to master the different
methods of reading and
writing with firebase.
>> All right, ready to start coding?